[Music]
okay let's watch uh let's watch that
vaping have you seen this from the
johnny depp trial yeah the witness that
just vaping during his testimony yeah
yeah he's in a scar who is this again
this is uber driver was it to the
courtroom
what was johnny like today on the drive
here
oh he's a nice guy that was johnny depp
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i couldn't tell he had
a mask on i don't i don't i don't i
don't ask the writers to wear a mask so
i thought it was weird that he wore a
mask
the incident was may 21st 2016.
you saw her the night of may 25th
correct
she said
uh amber heard hundreds of people
while she was they never heard treat you
well and was she friendly to you in each
of these hundreds of times
yes yes i i'm not gonna say no because
she was really always nice he's pulling
down the parking lot be nice
all right this is my last question you
testified in response to mr presidio's
questions um that you
testified truthfully in all of these
occasions this will get you banned from
twitch by the way
i truthfully truthfully to everything
that you testified in response to my
questions today
that's correct um that's correct
[Laughter]
that's correct i would have loved to
have taken that call and a [ __ ] yeah
dude a [ __ ] turboed
honda del sol
fat exhaust pipe honda del sol with the
[ __ ] t-top off man
just sung sunny's out
what up
what's up you're on sorry your honor i
got you on my bluetooth i can hear you
just fine
[Music]
on the [ __ ] 405
you saw mister hold up this turn is sick
strapping
just just uh refilled it with juice
topped it off you saw miss amber hold on
not buttons
yo hold up this dude wants to [ __ ]
run yo
third gear third gear pull hold on hold
on i'ma walk this kid hold on
in the middle
so when you saw miss
when
[Music]
mustangs blow dude i said when you saw
mr depp you guys want anything and i'll
get
cheese i think
what
can i get a double cheese uh-huh you
guys want anything are you good your
honor you're hungry it's crazy because
the subject matter of this case is
actually super [ __ ] serious all that
keeps getting passed around are vape
clips and johnny depp being like choke
me baby yeah
[Laughter]
it's kind of interesting i was looking
more into it this morning of course
because
i just i've i've been watching it every
single day
every day i watch it i think my new
thing after this is going to be law i
object
okay i object to that
objection your honor
hearsay oh okay [ __ ] so okay so it's
it's pretty clear at this point right
that amber heard is lying and she's kind
of insane is it yes okay that seems to
be like social media's take on
everything sure
but they don't it's not a super
clear-cut case just yet like he's suing
her for defamation
on the grounds that he lost this movie
role mainly pirate six
because of her op-ed and because of that
he lost out on 22 and a half million
dollars which was like the upfront fee
plus whatever percentage of the back end
he had right and lost the rest of his
career basically off that
and so that's the main thing he's suing
her for 50 million bucks i think which
are the damages caused by
the loss of pirate six and and a couple
other films after that but there's no
like i guess it was like a handshake
deal
between him and jerry bruckheimer
and like he was basically like just it
was kind of understood that he'd be part
of pirate six because he's one of the
most beloved characters in the whole
whole series right there's no contract
and there's no proof there's also a lot
of proof that people started to think
less of him as more of his like drinking
and stuff became more public and so
there's like kind of some proof that his
reputation started to decline before her
op-ed came out interesting that's her
that's like amber's defense defense is
basically like this didn't happen
because of me so irregardless of the
fact that that's not a word regardless
of the fact that she's lying about him
being the abuser which is [ __ ]
horrible he might still not win this
case i see isn't that crazy it's like
way more complex than i thought it was
oh of course i mean i i assumed as much
but i i
was just kind of like i'll wait to see
what the result is me too i mean like i
mean no i'm gonna watch it every single
[ __ ] day but so much it's six weeks
six weeks in total bro all day every day
you know you know though if he wins you
know the studio's gonna go like hey is
it that weird if we bring it back yeah
disney you mean yeah yeah they're gonna
knock on his door like jack dude dude i
mean john i mean johnny
oh sorry it's just you know that's what
i see when i look at you you know you
just i feel like you haven't really been
yourself he opens the door and he's like
mr sparrow
huh yeah come on come on i know we've
kind of had a little bit of a rough
patch but what do you say we take it we
bring it back huh people would love it
when we take a trip to davey's locker
full of money dude you know that trailer
would go [ __ ] bananas in the theater
yeah they'd premiere that [ __ ] at the
last arclight and every nerd would be
like yes that's what i'm i'm that's what
i'm saying
oh my god oh no or they bring it back
they replace johnny with the red and
black knight
[Laughter]
that [ __ ]
oh my god
sorry sorry johnny and congratulations
on the win but uh we tested you both
with the network and this kid's doing
well
that's really what we're trying to
target we're really targeting the
medieval times clientele the trial is
live right now on youtube and it has
over 300 000 concurrent viewers turn
that [ __ ] on
do not dude the fact that this thing has
as many viewers as fortnite did when it
first came out is
wild to me you see how many streamers
and stuff are like
how many views are being generated
from this yeah so xqc was watching this
[ __ ] and everyone has like 30 000
viewers yeah it's crazy you know what's
really funny is watching everyone speed
run the content creation pipeline yeah
yeah exactly all right something i enjoy
now is watching all these younger
youtubers uh do the commentary format
and watching them rediscover like okay
yeah so you're gonna find like the
misogyny guy
and then the virgin guy you know it took
us by the way we didn't invent that we
did not
find that too no we're just like you
know the third version of the matrix
yeah exactly now we're just watching the
youngins
yeah well well i think what's funny is
you know it took us like a good year
year and a half
to go through all the beats yeah right
and these kids they are speedrunning the
[ __ ] they're getting it done in three
months yeah and i laugh i'm like you
might want to slow this down because it
it falls off pretty quick i don't think
you understand that there's nothing left
after you discover all the archetype of
human
then you're doing out of pocket tick
tocks 95. we're so [ __ ] with media
like we're in a in a paywalled
podcast that is restreaming a stream
of uh you know what i mean
yeah like this is horrible
you